he's going into the Hall of Fame he's a
good friend Steve uh chanson how are you
hutch what's up rich are we doing Oh bro
come on now I'm I'm so happy for you I
know we took you out of a meeting but I
did tell the story of how I learned that
you got in the Hall of Fame I told this
story a few minutes ago
I hope I didn't embarrass you in front
of all your your new no no other members
no no no you listen at that point I
don't think you get it done anything
embarrass me I don't even know you know
I couldn't tell if I was walking I was
walking you know six inches above the
ground I don't know what I was doing
yeah I know you're walking down the
hallway with all your other fellow
members and I just saw you and I mean I
knew that meant you got in and and and
we just saw the video that land and your
wife took with you and your kids well
how does it walk we through your
emotions man walk we swim at the time
now how much different so at the time it
was you know the video says it all I
think you know and I kind of heard you
the back end you talking about why'd you
to get me last a little bit yeah you
know is a dress you know the pro the
hall does a good job of staggering the
guys so that when somebody gets good
news they're not next to a guy that
doesn't get bad news and in you can
imagine why and so I knew I was on the
15th floor I just didn't know if there
were any guys but I didn't know what
order were crime a reason you know and
so it was you know of course you know
I'm a schedule guy so on the schedule of
some dinning room at this time McGill
know between 2:30 and 3:30 either way
and so here it is 335 when I get to
knock so the last seven or eight minutes
were or they seem like an eternity Wow
now and I do they do you tell or do they
tell the hotel staff don't like offer
turndown service don't go anywhere near
Tori I would I would assume they do you
know I got up early that morning and
heard a hard time sleeping and so I my
wife and I grabbed a cup of coffee in
the lobby and I went to
front desk and I said just could you do
me a favor and make sure that they clean
my room service my room earlier we're
going out now so I just wanted I didn't
want to make sure there was any but I
had heard stories where there was a
knock on the door in the past few years
where it was it was you know you know
housekeeping uh wanting to know if they
needed towels or something so that I I
wanted to make sure that that that
didn't have happened to me but it didn't
happen you got David Baker knocking on
your door who did you think of outside
of your family first of Steve you know
it's really it's a it's it's hard to
explain
they say you're gonna think you know I
think coach Cowher said it best he said
that when you when I when I got when
David came and surprised him on set the
first thing he thought of this when he
was a kid in like what you know you
don't think of like you know he didn't
think of a hoist in the Super Bowl
trophy he didn't think about the you
know the grind of two-a-days it was you
know his mom driving him to practice as
a kid and I think what he meant by that
was you you almost have a flash for me I
started playing this game when I was six
years old and you know I retired I think
I was 36 and so it's almost like in an
instant the flash of everything and
really it was when I was a kid and it's
like how far you've come to get to this
point that's the first thing you go to
it's it's it's weird it's a it's a it
really is just kind of a snapshot of
everything all at once
and what is your proudest accomplishment
now that you can actually look back and
say okay this is all now officially a
Hall of Fame career and you can now
legitimately look back you can't say
well you know when it's all over when I
get right to this spot
now you can legitimately look back and
say this is what I'm proud of I'm proud
of us Steve I think I think it's
everything I've done along the way to
get to that point you know when you when
you play the game especially in the NFL
really all you all you ever want is
respect from the guys that came but
for you that you just want to you know
your dream is to be sitting at a
function and have a guy that you looked
up to come up to you and say you know
what that was a hell of a career you
played the game the right way that to me
that's the ultimate compliment you can
get you know you're gonna have your
family no matter what say wow you did a
great job whether you're not got beat
for five sacks in a game you know that's
that's a given right but when you have a
guy that you respect pay respect to you
and to me this is the ultimate you know
pat on the back from from that
standpoint where you know you're in that
Club and it's just it's a you have to do
everything right and you have to give it
everything you got on it any any time
you put your hand on the ground
any time you strap up that helmet in
order to get to this point and it just
kind of kind of confirms that I did it
that way now I you know I I went to a
Super Bowl and lost you know played in a
tough NFC Championship Game one game
away you know nine with the Vikings and
you know lost in New Orleans so I don't
have that hardware for the Super Bowl
which is you know everybody's goal when
you start playing this game and so there
was a little bit of a hold it was a void
left you know I felt that you know I
gave my all and in but I didn't have
anything really to show for it other
than up you know 12-year career and and
at the end of the day when that knock
came it was like man it just kind of in
my eyes it it legitimized it for me it
gave me closure and it just you know it
was great Steve Hutchinson Hall of Fame
inductee for the 20/20 class right here
on the Rich Eisen show and then after I
saw you in that hallway at honors and
then you got introduced on the stage and
this has been a neat thing the last
several honors years and this is
definitely not planned is that once the
entire class that's uh that's coming is
introduced every Hall of Famer that's in
the audience gets up and walks on the
stage who came up together what was that
moment like Steve first one I mean you
all of a sudden these guys flood the
stage you know and
and the first one in you know we've had
conversations over the last couple years
at the Merlin Olsen luncheon and some of
these on site at the Super Bowl leading
up to the vote and you know over the
Superbowl weekend first one was you know
Steve Largent he ran right up to me and
you know it it's really cool because
unlike some of these other teams that
have a rich you know storied tradition
of Hall of Famers in the Seahawks we
only got a couple of them you know and I
was fortunate to be in two amazing be a
part of two amazing outstanding
organizations and for the majority and I
spent a year in Tennessee at the end but
for the majority of my career you know
Seattle and Minnesota as you know and so
Largent came up and then then I think
after that the next one was LaDainian
and that was special because LaDainian
and i came out we were drafted the same
year we trained with the same agent we
trained together prior to the combine
and the draft and all that and and he
came up and and that was special and
then and then John Randle I spent and I
learned how to play the game going
against every day in practice my first
three years you know he came up and then
and then man Ray Lewis was there and you
know we were my first year we were
finalists together two years ago and
then bruce matthews who you know i think
he's the best to play the position you
know he came up and he coached me in
tennessee my last year it's just you
know it's it's it's unbelievable to be
flooded with all the guys that you like
I said earlier you grew up watching the
guys you respected you know man these
are the best guys to ever do it
and they come up and give you a hug and
congratulate you that's like you know
it's pretty overwhelming because span in
that hour there's a lot I know right and
then comes the Monday sort of
orientation with you and your your your
class right and then right and then
that's when you start talking about your
bust and all that business yeah I mean
that's when it kind of gets kind of gets
real he does some and download the
record tapes I gotta tell you a cool
funny story about that okay you go to
the orientation and and that's that's
kind of they put you you know they put
they have you David Baker wants every
to come up in you know we've got a
closed room and he wants you to give a
little talk about something well you
can't about yourself something you can't
really read in a bio so all the all the
UH the guys stood up and it was a
Centennial class along with the five of
us and he stand up and say a little
tidbit and there's some Hall of Famers
in the room that are helping us with
orientation and of course the rest of
the the hall staff from from Canton is
there so it's it's a it's a pretty good
sized room and that's when they also
when it's your turn they put your
picture on the on the overhead they say
your name and then that's when you find
out what number you are I am dumb crime
Hall of Famer numbers 335 which I
thought I was ironic because that's the
time David Baker not to my joke come
alive come on come on yeah I just I was
like oh you got to be kidding me this is
meant to be right yeah yes so it I
thought it was a little weird Wow
so what what era hutch are we gonna get
on the bust we're gonna get the flow
we're gonna get a little bit of a mullet
what are we gonna get what do you think
you know it's funny and I don't know how
many people know this story but when I
came out of Michigan you know you can
you can look up my life my combine
picture my mission tisha I was high and
tight with the short hair and the kind
of little flat top and the goatee and I
played my rookie year and you know I had
a good rookie year and then the second
year I got cut short I had an injury but
so I'm training I'm coming back and
trying to get ready for this for the
next season and I'm looking I'm going
you know what all these you know Pro
Bowl guys these guys that make the Pro
Bowl I'm like they all look me you know
I mean they just got the long hair and a
beard and that so I'm like I'm gonna
grow my hair out I'm gonna get a beard
then maybe that'll help me get the pro
one last year I went to football and I
watched seven straight so I think I'm
gonna have to give a little bit of a
little bit of a the flow in the beard
going and that's just when I'm thinking
now but I don't know walk to see what it
looks like once once the once we get
some renditions alright and before I let
you go Steve a couple more with Steve
Hutchinson Hall of Fame inductee here on
the Rich Eisen show you know the John
Madden says the busts talk to each other
when the lights go out right best you
can tell me right
best you can tell me what is your bust
and Brett Favre's bust gonna say to each
other when the lights go on Steve what's
gonna happen you know what you know what
it's gonna say it's gonna say so Brett
and I the two years we were together and
we haven't always we always sat next to
each other on the plane going to away
games okay and there was this we did
crossword puzzles on the on the plane
and then we want you know and then we
there was an app on the phone called
Sparkle it's like a trivia in wrestling
the trivia he's always you know Chris
Brett plays aw shucks Mississippi guy
but Brett spretz a very intelligent
person how I don't know if he wants
everybody to know on that but but he is
and so he can he can whip out a
crossword puzzle he can he so we would
play this game spork will play all these
random trivia games all the time and I
think if a far busts are going to talk
once they're done cleaning they turn the
lights out and I we're just going to be
we're gonna we're gonna have some way to
pull up random trivia and we're going to
just we're going to quiz each other
that's it okay talk about how I flew
down we might talk about how I flew down
one time and try to kidnap by the way
that's Hall of Fame worthy necessity in
a duck blind or some oh yeah you talked
about that yeah yeah we might we might
who's you know Brett he might have
brought that up staring ahead we after
the show and we all went back to the
hotel and that we happen to be dinner at
the same same restaurant and when he
came over and we were talking about that
a little bit and it's funny I mean it's
crazy things you do for this game right
it's amazing and and before the last one
for you I'm gonna go here Steve I'm
gonna go here a lot of folks may not
know when was the first time you met
your wife Steve when did you meet your
wife English class and she was picking
up attendance cards and so she just had
transferred I guess there was that
summer she transferred as early and
there really hadn't seen her yet and she
came in and I said you know kind of like
that one and then here we are that's
right so we were you know and so married
two kids and still going strong eighth
grade so folks may not realize you're
not the only one going into Canton man
it's her - she was there every step of
the way no I mean like this is her this
is her Hall of Fame moment - so what
does this mean for her and the family
that we saw in that video well I mean
she's been there I mean a lot of people
say well you know this one's she's been
there from the beginning this one has
literally been there my wife has been
there from the beginning she's been
through all the surgeries all you know
all the not glorious things about the
league that's behind the curtains you
know when when you when you you know you
play so many seasons and I can't I can't
tell you how many times I've held off
surgeries on shoulders till after the
season to make it through and then you
know it's like you know look you know
it's just time for vacation this time
for this well know I'm getting a surgery
and I'm laid up on the couch and she's
running the to the to the pharmacy to
get refills on this so she's you know
changing bandages and and you know it it
she's been through it all I mean the the
the moving the moving from see I you
know moving from Florida to Seattle and
then just at the drop of a hat you know
picking up and moving to Minnesota and
then moving to Tennessee and taking the
kids and you know making sure that
everything from the from the standpoint
of the house and and everything that so
when I came home from work you know it
was we were it was a machine you know
and that and it's just as much her as as
it is me because I didn't have the
support at home it you know who knows
you know and so it is very very much
true it is it's just as much for her so
I think that's why it was emotional for
her as it was for for me when that knock
happened at 3:35 and Pro Football Hall
of Famer number 335 Steve Hutchinson
thank you for calling in I love you my
man I'm very very
and landing and attention and all of all
the Hutchinson's and you're all
everybody that love me too rich I'm in
it
you know it we've come a long way you
know and remember back you know years
ago you um seeing the our golf
tournament back in oh yeah back in
Michigan and and and I mean just you
know talking about this at some point
and you know it's like back then it's
like it's just it's a it's a million
miles away and and now here it is I know
you've been there for you know a big
part of it and along the way and Izumo
over at the Pro Bowl all our parties and
at one time in San Diego where you keep
perpetuating than one thought I wasn't
you took a microphone out of an LD
million elderly man's hand a karaoke
stage that Brockman says had a guy tried
to trump you on stage karaoke bar when
you're trying to sing a little a little
Sinatra and and you know I was like I
mean I've never seen my take to karaoke
so serious and I will never do that
trust me I'll never do that to you hey
Steve one day I'll get the knock on the
door for karaoke Hall of Fame and you'll
be there when we go in together take
care of yourself best I landed take care
brother
Congrats that Steve Hutchinson for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app